ｺﾝﾁｬはじめしゃちょーとあっちそっちよっちです　（腹パン）
はじめ(以下、は)「はい皆さん
というわけで、いまお昼時でございます...
...が」　は「我々お腹が減っておりますと」
よっち(以下、👓)「お腹が減っております」
は「デリバリー頼もう」
👓「デリバリー！？」
は「ん(*´ω｀*)」
👓「何のデリバリー？」
は「ピザ食べたい」
👓「ピッツァ！あ、いいですねピッツァ」
は「最近ピザグミ作ってたしょ」
👓「ピザグミ作ってました」
は「ピザもグミも好きなのにグミ食べれないから」
は「ピザグミ食べれなくて」
は「その嫌な思い出をコメントしといた🐘💢！」
👓「wwwすぐ僕返しましたｗｗそれｗｗ」
は「はいというわけでピザを食べたいんですけどモウ🐮」
👓「はい...」
は「今日は👓（よっち）もせっかく家に来てるんで」
は「あのー...ちょっと特殊な頼み方で」
は「今回もせっかく運んでくださる方モウ🐮」
👓「はい」
は「多分普通にピザ受け取っても楽しくないから」
👓「ﾌｽｨwww」
は「迷惑にならない
レベルの」
👓「EARTH!🌏そうですね（１）」
は「パフォーマンスをして」
👓「そうですね（２）」
は「こうね、楽しんで…エンターテイメントをして」
は「ピザ屋の人もなるべく楽しく」
は「ピザを渡しに来てくれたら良いなという！」
👓「ﾐﾝﾅﾊｯﾋﾟｰ（？）」　は「😏（腹パン）」
👓「ｱｳﾞｧww」
は「というわけで今回！二人羽織って
皆さんご存知でしょうか？」
は「分かる？」
👓「僕はやったことがあるんで分かるんですけど」
は「ナンナンなの元はなんなの？」
👓「あれ元は」
👓「フクロウ（？）まぁ服があるんですけど」
👓「そん中に2人入って、
1人は何もしないで見るんですけど」
👓「もう１人は、なんかその人の手の役割をする」
は「えーっと。。１つの服に２人入って」
👓「そうですね（３）」
は「顔は前の人だけど」
👓「顔は前の人です」
は「手が後ろの人っていうね」
👓「そうです（４）」
は「なるほど（１）」
👓「これホントにチームワークないと　できない」
は「なるほど（２）今回それでちょっとピザを受け取ろうかな」
は「wwww」
👓「HAHAHAHA！大丈夫か...」
は「一回練習しようぜ」
👓「一回練習...」
は「うわぁ!（苦しみのリアクション）」
👓「いやいやｗｗｗｗ洗いました洗いましたｗｗ」
👓「あっ、ここにあるじゃないすか！ここにあr...」
👓「ﾇﾜｧｧｧｧｧｧ!!!ﾊﾟﾌﾟｱﾆｭｰｷﾞﾆｱ」
は「ｗｗｗｗ」
は「これオカシイなｗ３日前に買ったんだけどなｗｗ」
👓「ｱﾊｯｗ」
は「ケンブリッジ（飛鳥）氏(?)」
👓「あーお腹痛い」
は「待ってこれ俺…腕どうすればいいんだろう」
は「あれあれ俺これ難しくね？
二人羽織ってどうやってするの？」
は「え、絶対締まんなくねこれ…二人羽織無理じゃん」
は「ｱｯｼﾞｬｻﾓｰｻ!!こーゆうのでやろう」
👓「前の人裸のほうが良いんじゃないスカ？」
👓「いま風呂上がりです」
は「あー風呂上がり感出してく？」
👓「そうです（５）」
は👓「ｸﾞｸﾞｯ///」
は「ねぇ///密着感凄い♡」
👓「いらっしゃーい///（慣れた手つきで）」
は「ｱｧー♂」
は「グロいグロい(〃∇〃)グロいグロい(〃∇〃)」
👓「ｗｗ」
👓「いやもうこれやるしかないでしょはじめさん（使命感）」
👓「やるしかないです！モウ🐮これはモウ🐮」
👓「避けられない！これはモウ🐮避けられない」
は「なんで毎回ホモホモしくなるのｗｗｗ」
は「うえ～ん///」
👓「ｳﾌﾌﾌﾌﾌ///」
は「待って待って
で、どうすればいいんだ？これで行こう」
は「これどう！？」
👓「全然僕見えないんですよ」
は「いま、凄い×２ほら、お、できてる」
は『俺の腕じゃないですからね
というわけでですね」
は「いま、これ僕の腕じゃなくて
後ろにいる
は「👓（よっち）の手でございます。凄いでしょ」
は「で、今回これを使って」
は「ちょっとピザ屋さんのピザを受け取って」
は「なるべく
その～ちょっとね」
は「ピザ受け取るときは僕じゃなくて
👓（よっち）が前になるんで」
は「なるべくね
ちょっとありえない腕の動きをして」
は「ピザ屋さんの人をね、少しでも！」
は「二人羽織？（Q）」
👓「二人羽織（A）」
は「少しでもね、ピザ屋さんの人をこの二人羽織りで」
は「楽しい気持ちにさせれればいいなと
思っております」
は「でわ行こう！」　SE『ﾋﾟﾆｮ×２』
は「デリバリー頼みたいんですけど」
謎の生命体X「ﾃﾞﾘﾊﾞﾘｰﾃﾞｽﾈｰ ﾊｲｱﾘｶﾞﾄｳｺﾞｻﾞｲﾏｽ」
謎の生命体X「ｺﾞﾁｭｳﾓﾝﾉｼﾅｵﾈｶﾞｲｼﾏ~ｽ」
は「はい」
謎の生命体X「ﾊｲ　ﾃﾞﾊｻﾝｼﾞｭｯﾌﾟﾝｾﾞﾝｺﾞﾃﾞ」
謎の生命体X「ｵﾄﾄﾞｹﾃﾞｷﾙｶﾄｵﾓｲﾏ~ｽ」
は「はい、はい」
は「よろしくお願いします」
謎の生命体X「ｱﾘｶﾞﾄｳｺﾞｻﾞｲﾏ~ｽ」
は「はぁーい」
は「というわけでピザの注文完了したので、後は」
は「待つだけでございます」
👓「はい(｀・ω・´)b」
？？？「ﾝ゛ﾝ゛ｰ」
空振り×２
👓「あ、すいません。ちょっとお風呂入ってて」
👓「はい、ありがとうございます」
✋ﾊﾟﾗﾘﾗww✋ﾊﾟﾗﾘﾗww✋ﾊﾟﾗﾘﾗww✋ﾊﾟﾗﾘﾗww✋ﾊﾟﾗﾘﾗww✋ﾊﾟﾗﾘﾗww✋ﾊﾟﾗﾘﾗww✋ﾊﾟﾗﾘﾗww✋ﾊﾟﾗﾘﾗww✋ﾊﾟﾗﾘﾗww✋ﾊﾟﾗﾘﾗww✋ﾊﾟﾗﾘﾗww✋
✋ｽﾞｼｬwｽﾞｼｬwｽﾞｼｬwｽﾞｼｬwｽﾞｼｬwｽﾞｼｬwｽﾞｼｬw✋
👓「あ、はい」
は「✋(SE「ﾌｩﾝ」)　✋(SE「ﾌｩﾝ」)」
👓「はい、ありがとうございます。
ありがとうございます」
👓「ｱﾓﾄﾞｯｼｬ　ﾐﾃﾞｨﾐﾃﾞｨﾐｄ..」
🍕「熱いですけど（食い気味）」
👓「大丈夫です大丈夫です、はい」
👓「（鎮まれ...俺の右腕...）」
は「✋スッ　ｼｬｶｼｬｶｼｬｶｼｬｶ」
👓「あ、ちょと　あ...えーと」
👓「ｺﾞｗﾆｭｗﾍｗﾇｗﾊｗｗｗｗ」
🍕「ｗｗｗｗ」
👓「Eｗｗｱｗﾋｗﾃﾞｗﾂｗｸﾞｗｗｗｗｗ」
👓🍕「ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ」
（炭酸水「ﾋﾞﾁﾋﾞﾁﾋﾞﾁﾋﾞﾁﾋﾞﾁﾋﾞﾁﾋﾞﾁﾋﾞﾁﾋﾞﾁﾋﾞﾁﾋﾞﾁ」）
👓「すいません」
🍕「大丈夫ですよｗｗ」
は「人（手を合わせる）」
🍕「あー大丈夫ですよｗｗ」
👓「ｗｗｗｗｗ」
🍕「2,110円です」
🍕「ちょーどお預かりします」
SE「ｼﾞｬｰﾝwwｼﾞｬｰﾝwwｼﾞｬｰﾝww」
🍕「レシートです、はい。」
👓「あ、レシート、はい、ありがとうございます」
SE「ﾋﾟｭﾝ×3」
👓「ありがとうございます(小声)」
🍕「あ、ありがとうございます。」
🍕「またよろしくお願いしまーす」
は「ノシ」
🍕「ありがとうございましたー！」
👓「ｱﾘｶﾞﾄｳｺﾞｻﾞｲﾏｼﾀｰ(小声)」
は「ノシ」
👓「ちょっと...w」
は「ｲﾗﾈ!!(*ﾟДﾟ)ノ⌒ﾟ 👓」
ε≡≡ﾍ( ´Д`)ﾉ
は「AHAHAHAHAｗｗｗ」
( ³ω³ )「やり過ぎｗｗｗｗやり過ぎ...ｗｗ」
（ ³ω³ ）「これｗｗこれｗｗ」
👓「めっちゃいい人じゃないすか」
は「よかったね」
👓「よかったですぅ」
は「笑ってくれてよかった」